♫ Musique ♫
*Craquement de skateboard*
♫ Musique du générique ♫
« Être adulte c'est aussi accepter qu'on est plus un enfant. »
♫ Musique ♫
Maman, tu frappes avant d'entrer !
Ah oui pardon ! *Semblant d'être désolé*
*Toc toc* TOC TOC, c'est maman !
Alors voilà...
Tu fais quoi ?
Je vais donner tes vieux jouets à Enzo, il sera content !
Non non non ! Je... Je les garde je les garde.
Toi, pourquoi tu veux les garder ?
Tu veux dire que je vais être mamie ! Non arrête avec ça ; non non, c'est des figurines c'est pas des jouets Enzo est trop petit pour jouer avec ça c'est tout
Enzo trop petit pour jouer avec ta  tortue extra mutante de l'espace ?
N'importe quoi c'est une tortue ninja hein et puis c'est pas n'importe qui c'est Leonardo le leader tu devrais le savoir
T'es pas un peu grand pour jouer avec ces trucs. Non !
Ouais
Tata m'a dit que t'avais des jouets pour moi . Des jouets... euh non non. Et ça c'est quoi ?
Euh non non non c'est de la collection ça n'a rien à voir
Si j'ai quelque chose pour toi, quelque chose de super tu vas... Voilà tiens c'est pour toi
C'est quoi ?  C'est une main collante quand j'étais gamin j'adorais jouer avec ça
Là effectivement elle colle plus trop mais c'est une main gluante et c'est super cool
Mais t'as pas des vrais jouets comme ça là
Hop hop hop eh Enzo
Tu sais moi à ton âge j'avais pas les tablettes la réalité virtuelle tout ça on voit tout ce que j'avais c'était une main collante
Et ça m'allait très bien. Et ton jouet bat man ?
Et toi qu'est ce que tu as répondu ? Maman ? Oui ? T'as donné mon bat man camouflage de nuit à Enzo ?
Deux petites secondes Vero y a mon fils de 27 ans qui fait un caprice
Mais c'est, mais ça n'a rien à voir avec un caprice j'aimerais juste savoir pourquoi t'as donné MON bat man camouflage de nuit sans même me consulter
Parce que tu as vingt sept ans et que ça va bientôt faire 15 ans que t'as pas joué à tes jouets
Et alors c'est une figurine de collection
Hein en 15 ans elle a doublé de prix facile ! On l'a acheté 100 francs. Eh ben ça fait 200 francs donc euh
30 euros
Ok ouais mais la valeur sentimentale hein ça n'a pas de prix ça  !
Euh bah merci Enzo c'est gentil
Je trouve ça nul si nos parents ils donnent nos jouets à d'autres enfants sans nous demander. Ah bah oui voilà
Enfin quelqu'un avec du bon sens dans cette famille
Moi si ma maman elle me prenait Leonardo je serais trop en colère. Leonardo le... la tortue ninja ? Tu connais ? Bah bien sûr que je connais c'est toute mon enfance
Ma maman, elle connaît pas du tout, elle
Elle dit que c'est une tortue extraterrestre mais c'est pareil mais il faut sortir un petit peu. Et Schredder tu l'as aussi en figurine
Tu sais quoi Vero la prochaine fois qu'il vient j'ai peur qu'il me demande de porter le collier de nouilles qu'il m'a fait il y a 20 ans
« Je suis Leonardo et toi qui es-tu ? »
« Je suis aussi Leonardo, je suis ton double maléfique du passé. »
Il est nul ton jouet regarde
Pourquoi qu'est ce qu'il a ? Bah moi j'ai une hache de guerre donc j'te bats
Est ce qu'une hache de guerre ça gagne contre ... un dinosaure parfaitement dressé !!!
Super
Waaaaah !!!
« Allons chercher de la nourriture. » Tu sais quoi Enzo ?
Je te file le dinosaure et aussi mon vieux Leonardo
Et même mon Dark Vador j'avoue je l'avais planqué dans ma poche je voulais pas te le filer . C'est à toi
Merci trop cool yeees!
« Leonardo du passé tu vas mourir »
« Tous les jeux du passé je vais les détruire sauf moi » Nickel !
Tu m'en veux pas hein t'es quasiment pas la de l'année ! Mais c'est ma chambre ! Super.
*générique d'outro* (Musique) #Jambon